[Music]
you are watching the press preview a
first look at what's on the front pages
as they arrive it's time to see what's
making the headlines with the guardians
chief political correspondent jessica
elgot and the conservative commentator
tim montgomery so let's see what's on
some of those front pages for you now
the telegraph leads with the question
surrounding prince andrew after the
guilty verdict in galen maxwell's trial
he denies any wrongdoing
the mirror speaks to a witness from the
trial with the headline andrew must tell
all he knows
the mail says the prince should be
quaking in his boots
meanwhile covert dominates some of the
other papers the guardian warned that a
lack of tests for nhs staff could have
devastating impact
the star calls the lack of testing kits
daylight swabbery with a picture there
of david jason in only fools and horses
scotland's the national quotes from what
it calls an smp end-of-year school card
which describes the conservative
government as corrupt on all counts
and according to the financial times
worldwide mergers and acquisitions deals
in 2021 were worth a total of 5.8
trillion dollars
joining me tonight to take us through
the papers jessica elgot and tim
montgomery welcome to you both uh
jessica let's start with you and the
front page of the mirror their headline
there as i was saying andrew must tell
all he knows
yes and and and you know
considering you know
considering how bad it could have been
um andrew didn't
he didn't face as much scrutiny as he
could have done
during during maxwell's actual trial but
he's not going to be able to dodge that
spotlight in the new year um when he's
sued for this alleged um sexual assault
and
um
she's doing a new york court um for the
next stage of her civil action against
him and and and this will you know
although he hasn't been the center of
attention of this trial and because
virginia geoffrey was wasn't called as a
witness and he's certainly going to to
to have you know the spotlight back on
him in the new year when she sues him so
it's really is that the the start of of
of the tournament i think for for prince
andrew over over this this terrible
episode
tim
yeah but i think most of us are grateful
for some respite from kovitz stories but
certainly someone who won't be grateful
will be i think prince andrew clearly
the focus is now on him
and on reports that 300 other british
people
in gillane maxwell's sort of diarrhea
contacts
are also being approached by authorities
so obviously a lot of those people will
be completely innocent of anything but
the police the authorities are trolling
her contacts list for people who might
in some way have been part of the sex
trafficking ring that she's been found
guilty of being part of so yes um there
is a certain member of the royal family
who will be worried but i think the uh
the big challenge now uh for the police
and other investigating authorities on
both sides of the atlantic is to find
the other people
that were the beneficiaries of this
terrible abuse of young women
yes and uh we we must reiterate that uh
prince andrew has uh strenuously denied
all um accusations leveled against him
the mail we saw there their headline
though saying quaking in his boots
jessica
yes and i think that um one of the
things this this trial shows is that
there was i think there was a an air
around
epstein um of a kind of an
untouchability of a bit you know a
billionaire and able to do whatever he
liked and get away with whatever he
liked and and to a certain extent around
maxwell as well
and uh no more so is there an aura of
that around you know the members of the
royal family where you know sometimes
it's felt like rules haven't applied and
now there is a justice system seeking to
get to the truth now he denies it and
and you know from his perspective
potentially justice will find him
completely innocent but um but what this
i think that there's one of the things
that this shows is that these these
kinds of horrible crimes can can catch
up with you and and thank god they do
they did in this circumstance um but but
that will you know will worry people who
have got something to hide
let's see
sorry go ahead tim
i'm just going to say jillian you're
absolutely right to say you know prince
andrew um affirms his innocence on all
of this and that is absolutely the due
process but at the very least i think we
all know he has been guilty of a massive
error of judgment you know in continuing
for example to visit epstein even after
him being convicted of um sexual
offenses so he is he may be innocent of
the main charges but he certainly um
deserves i think a lot of the public uh
discussed at um how he's behaved
let's move on to the guardian um and
this story um looking at the lack of of
cover test the fact that there aren't
enough tests to to go around and perhaps
prioritizing sanji javid is suggesting
that nhs workers need to be prioritized
in terms of getting the kids to to avert
disaster
jessica yeah i mean and this is really
the kind of biggest mounting issue i
think that there is around that this
astonishing number of
of covered infections that there are
currently i mean i i'm sure all of us
know the most amount of people who've
got kobe that we've ever known
throughout the whole pandemic and um
and you know 189 000 um today uh well
obviously that's not necessarily 189 000
people today but you know that that's
the figure for the for the infections
today um and and so we've been and those
you know understandably so there's
there's uh a lack of tests because of
the sheer numbers and uh the health
secretary standard javid is being urged
to ensure that nhs workers prioritize
for these tests because otherwise um
there could be a huge impact on patient
care i mean you know potentially there
is already already going to be because
of the numbers of staff uh isolating um
but the bma said that which is the the
uni represents doctors saying that you
know the system for ensuring that staff
gets the test is just not working at the
moment and then that's pcr tests and
natural slowness even though healthcare
workers are supposedly being given
priority but there's also calls for
other really essential workers like
teachers to get the priority access to
these tests because you know otherwise
we're going to have huge sways of the
teaching staff um isolating and although
boris johnson said he's absolutely
determined to keep schools open if
there's no teachers to teach and then
that's going to make the return to
school very difficult so um i think i
think one of the big difficulties of
this wave of pandemic that we're going
to see is this uh what what number 10
likes to call workplace resilience um
which is basically that there's no one
to to to drive trains or to teach uh
schools or to to treat people in
hospitals because everybody's isolating
yeah and another factor sort of boosting
the demand is that the self-isolation
period as we know in england has been
cut from 10 days to seven days and that
allows for two negative tests and um
tim you were nodding along there because
you've just come out of isolation
yourself
well i i hope almost you know i've had a
pretty miserable seven days of the last
seven days over christmas i've been
completely self-isolating um i've had my
first uh positive test today and since
that i can i'm free of kobe i have
another one tomorrow
and i'm hoping for what one friend
called a new year mass uh sort of
celebrate christmas at a new year um but
you know there's other good news i i
think from south africa we've learned
today that the president there ramaphosa
has said that the the peak of infections
has now passed there and you know the
guardian describes and the bma warning
about a devastating i think that's the
word uh you know challenge facing the
national health service and of course we
have to be on alert but i'm getting a
little bit tired with the general sort
of
media gl doom and gloom about all of
this everything is devastating or crisis
or whatever actually i think we should
now be clear
that omicon is not the great threat that
we worried that it was a month or so ago
yes we need to be vigilant yes there is
a problem of availability of tests and
it does seem sensible to prioritize key
workers but can we all calm down a
little bit more uh but
are we still waiting on on more data to
to arrive at that conclusion i mean
we've we've heard today these uh
nightingale uh spur hospitals are
springing up so we don't seem to be out
of the woods as you're suggesting
i'm not suggesting that we're completely
out of the woods i've just said we need
to be vigilant but continuing to sort of
freeze lives freeze the economy on the
basis of you know absolute precautionary
principle that things may still get
worse when actually the overwhelming
evidence that we do have so far is that
omicron really is very transmissible but
from the vast majority of people who
receive it it's no worse than a cold you
know i have been self-isolating for the
last seven days i've had no ill effects
at all i've been hopefully sensible i
haven't gone home you know to infect or
risk my elderly parents but actually
it's had no you know negative effects on
me at all and i think you know the the
movement of the uh quarantine period
down from ten to seven days is sensible
america of course have moved to five
days and i i hope britain might follow
that example before too long
uh jessica do you agree with with tim
that there's probably a bit of do
mongering going on
i mean i think that there is i think
that obviously it's good that omicron
has not you know i think that we
shouldn't be afraid when we're writing
news stories to write to write positive
things that you know when that when the
evidence emerges that omicron is is
milder or there's fewer hospitalizations
or long stays in hospital with omicron
then that's
you know clearly a positive thing um i
think you know as as you'll hear chris
whitty often uh caution that
when you have such high infection rates
then you
you know that a small percentage of a
large number is still a very large
number and and therefore you know that's
one of the reasons why um there is a you
know
there is a there is a need to for
caution and also extremely high
infection rates also um as far as i
understand it and i've heard i've heard
people say on that downing street podium
means that there's more likely for new
variants to to evolve um you know when
there's such high case rates so i don't
i think that we shouldn't be i don't
think we should necessarily think that
we're in a great situation and
especially when it comes to you know
i've seen today you know huge sways of
the rail network having to be cancelled
because staff just can't get into to man
the trains but
you know i agree with him we're in a
better we're in a much better situation
than we than we are than we were in this
time last year when it when it really
felt like you know was standing in the
middle of the abyss apart from you know
the only glimmer of hope we had was the
vaccine on the horizon and that that
seems to be the thing that is really
saving us this time round that we're not
seeing as many serious illnesses and and
certainly not seeing as many deaths
because because there's so many people
vaccinated and we've had such a great
vaccine effort in this country and it is
worrying how many people are still
unvaccinated and how those people still
seem to be the ones who who are who you
know who are getting
the most ill from from this variant and
it's hard to see how much how much more
convincing you need to take a vaccine
than than seeing some of those
statistics let's let's move on to the
divide and opinion according to
reporting the financial times as to
whether children age five to eleven
should be uh vaccinated tim your
thoughts
yeah i
i sort of slightly tangential julian
perhaps i'm not gonna answer your
question but my general view is you know
children aren't that vulnerable to covid
and this sort of underlines to me
sort of a problem i think we've had in
the west we're trying to completely
protect ourselves from this virus by
vaccinating ever more people
ever more often and actually i think
it's much more likely that we would
protect ourselves if we were more
generous with people in the developing
world you know there's still many parts
of the world which haven't really had
any serious uh levels of vaccination and
i think we protect our children we'll
affect our older people we'd affect the
most vulnerable members in society
actually in fact gordon brown has um
recommended former prime minister we
were more generous to um the poorer
parts of the planet um we will share and
um so i have mixed views on vaccinating
children but it seems to me largely
besides the point let's have a look at
the financial times and uh take us back
to those downing street flat
refurbishments what is the very latest
that we're hearing
yes so um the the latest and it'll be a
sigh of relief for boris johnson is that
his uh independent adviser and
ministerial standards lord gait
is going to clear him again of
wrongdoing now this is an investigation
that lord guy has had to reopen into the
downing street flat refurbishments
because there seemed to be
quite significant inconsistency between
who
between his report that he first where
he first killed the prime minister which
is quite a few months ago and the
electoral commission which looked into
the actions of the conservative party
around it which found that there were
some sort of grievous errors um or
mistakes or you know missions
uh in the way that the donations for for
this lavish refurbishment was were
reported um
and so therefore they admonished the
conservative party and gave them a
rather large fine um and it and it
seemed like that boris johnson had
misled
lord guyt uh by by saying he hadn't been
aware of uh
the of the involvement of his donor lord
brownlow until february then the
electoral commission had some whatsapps
from november so it appeared that lord
might you know be
resignation but he uh he seems to have
reconciled himself to it so he said we
read in the financial times today and um
and uh he's just going to say that there
was a
few few uh silly mistakes made and clear
boris johnson again and i suspect this
isn't going to do an awful lot um to to
restoring fake in the way that that
politicians um are monitored or looked
after you know or all their standards
are are looked after especially in the
face of you know some of the things
we've seen over the last few months you
know boris johnson's attempt to uh
revoke some of the powers of the
parliamentary standards commissioner
another another watchdog so um so we'll
see what the fallout yes but tim it does
still seem to be that uh the prime
minister's conduct
will be criticized
yes and it won't help his authority
within the conservative party or or the
nation i think um
that's been speaking to conservative mps
and so on a little bit over the period
and i think the feverishness
about his uh position as prime minister
has probably subsided i think that the
best thing he has going for him is the
lack of consensus about an alternative
uh to prime minister to take over him
for from him but i think the thing that
would change the opinion of conservative
mps is if we have a big another sort of
ethical
question over him if for example you
know we learned that he has misled
parliament particularly over the the
question of parties in down history he's
only sort of one or two things like that
away from his leadership still being
challenged so
it's vital really for his future that he
contains an issue like this it seems
from what the ft has reported is
reporting
that he might just have done enough to
stop that resignation that jessica
mentioned it's even possible uh
previously but clearly he's uh he's at
very best very least his uh arrangements
in his organization are chaotic if not
unethical jessica very quickly we've got
about 30 seconds uh to tell us about the
unseasonably warm temperatures well i
don't know if it's probably an
exaggeration on the front of the
guardian to take us into the new year
yes well i mean i i for all for those of
us who like to spend new year's day in a
bracing walk uh you know that's that's
that's quite cheering news although um
you know unseasonably we are seeing all
these kind of unseasonably warm and uh
days or or extreme weather and i think
you know that's for those of us that are
concerned about climate change now we
don't want to be the the traditional
guardian gloomster but it is something
that you know makes us all look all the
more worried but i'm sure that some of
us can still enjoy the sunshine on a new
year walk as well yes yes i don't know
if i'll go so far as going to the beach
but uh yes a long walk would be
recommended jessica and tim thank you
very much see you in the next